oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith
the feed goes silent and so does the
audience after will smith takes a swing
at chris rock on stage at the oscars it
all went down after chris made a crack
about will's wife jada pinkett smith and
her shaved head
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
while will appears to laugh at first
things immediately turned sour as he
takes to the stage slapping chris
straight across the face oh richard
oh wow
wow
the sound on the broadcast suddenly cut
out in the moments following the
altercation but international markets
saw the feed in full will shouting at
the top of his lungs keep my wife's name
out of your mouth
clearly shaken and unsure how to proceed
chris responds the best way he knows how
with another joke
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
so what happened next e.t has learned
that denzel washington and tyler perry
pulled will aside for a private chat
during the commercial break that
followed denzel was up against his pal
for the best actor trophy at the show i
mean you know it's a lot of emotions
this is a long time well i think a long
time coming for him and it's a lot of
emotion it's probably all welling up in
him right now so
it better be him the trio hugged and it
appeared things had calmed down a source
tells e.t quote the theater was silent
after will got up and hit chris no one
could tell if it was staged or a joke at
first it was incredibly awkward for the
whole audience will's friends and team
have been trying to calm him down
oh wow
wow
as for why the joke may have hit a nerve
for the couple jada was diagnosed with
alopecia in 2018 a hair loss condition
which she has spoken about publicly many
times
y'all know i've been struggling with
alopecia and
just all of a sudden one day
look at this line right here
look at that
look at that
and so it just showed up like that now
this is gonna be a little bit more
difficult for me to hide
so i thought i'd just share it so you're
not asking any questions and earlier in
the night co-host regina hall made a jab
at jada which could have also
contributed to will storming the stage
will smith um
you're married but you know what you're
on the list and looks like jada approved
you so you get on that bill
it's also worth noting chris made digs
about jada when he hosted the show back
in 2016 too so there's history here
will got a chance to address the
incident when he won the best actor
honor his first ever academy award you
got to be able to have people talk crazy
about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay art imitates
life i look like the crazy father list
like they said
i look like crazy father just like they
said about richard williams
um
but love will make you do crazy things